شعله دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه لعام 2024
تطالها رياح تهديدات المقاطعه بينما تسير
فرنسا على قدم وساق في تجهيزات
الاستعدادات للدوره المرتقبه تحول بولندا
قياده حمله مقاطعه لها من خلال تحالف مكون
من اربعين دوله
هدفنا هو ان الروس والبيلاروس لن يكونوا
حاضرين في الالعاب الاولمبيه من خلال
تحالف واسع برئاسه بريطانيا وامريكا لن
يكون للالعاب الاولمبيه اي معنى على
الاطلاق
تصريحات وزير الرياضه البولندي تاتي عقب
اعتراض كل
منتوانيا واستونيا على خطه اللجنه
الاولمبيه بالسماح للرياضيين من روسيا
وبيلاروسيا بالمشاركه في الالعاب المقرره
لعام 2004
محاولات اعاده الرياضيين من روسيا
وبيلاروسيا للمشاركه في المنافسات
الرياضيه الدوليه وان كان ذلك تحت رايه
حياديه يطفى الشرعيه على القرارات
السياسيه والدعايه التي تنشرها الدولتان
تحت وطاه السياسه تواجه دوره الالعاب
الاولمبيه في باريس مصيرا غير واضح اما
اللجنه الاولمبيه فتصمم على ابعاد السياسه
عن الملاعب الرياضيه المقاطعه تعد انتهاكا
للمثاق الاولمبي الذي يلزم جميعا لجانب
المشاركه في الاولمبياد وارسال رياضيات
ويشهد التاريخ ان قرارات المقاطعه السابقه
لم تحقق اهدافها السياسيه وكلما فعلته هو
معاقبه الرياضيين
دعوات لابعاد السياسه عن الرياضه يواجهها
تصميم اوكراني على تنفيذ تهديدها
بالمقاطعه بسبب استهداف نحو 3004 ملعبا
رياضيا في اوكرانيا الى جانب وفاه 220
رياضيا ومدربا وعاملا وفق تصريحات وزير
الرياضه الاوكرانيه
اما امريكا فتواصل دعم موقف اوكرانيا
المصحوب بحملات مقاطعه اوروبيه واسعه
لتبقى دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه المقبله في
باريس على محاكي تصعيد متزايد ومواجهه في
ملاعب السياسه وضغوطها علي السمان العربيه